with the private sector so weakened by
this recession the federal government is
the only entity left with the resources
to jolt our economy back into life the
eight hundred and forty billion dollar
stimulus bill pump money into every
community in the country to pay for
things like transit infrastructure tax
breaks weatherizing homes and keeping
teachers on the payroll economist
Veronique doraji is a senior research
fellow at the Mercatus Center at George
Mason University and an expert on the
stimulus the administration said that
unemployment would reach likely eight
point eight percent without the stimulus
but that was the stimulus he would never
reach that level and in fact it would
start going down really quickly the
reality is it actually has gone way past
the eight point eight percent and hover
above nine percent for the last two
years reason TV did a case study looking
at how the stimulus money was spent in
one community in Obama's backyard the
town of Silver Spring Maryland a
commuter suburb of Washington DC even if
you were to believe that government
spending can trigger economic growth the
money is never spent in a way that is
consistent with the condition laid out
by the kansian for it to be efficient
nearly 400,000 men and women will go to
work rebuilding our crumbling roads and
bridges repairing our faulty dams and
levees bringing critical broadband
connections to businesses and homes in
nearly every community in America in
fact the u.s. construction industry shed
about a million jobs in the year after
the stimulus was passed and two and a
half years later the industry still
hasn't recovered Maryland's specialty
trade construction industry which
handles big infrastructure projects has
shed about 8,000 jobs since the stimulus
was passed meanwhile stimulus money has
steadily paid the salaries of only 600
construction workers in Maryland since
the middle of 2009 so why did the
stimulus create so few construction jobs
for one thing many the project's paid
for by the stimulus would have happened
anyway the resurfacing of this highway
in Silver Spring is the first stimulus
project in the nation to get shovels in
the ground it was also fairly typical it
was a routine repair job instead of
actually thinking about where the money
we need to go to hire those itll
resources infrastructure spending when
two jobs that were already lined up or
it went to actually pay the salary you
were already on the job but Maryland got
seven hundred and seventy 1 million
stimulus dollars for transit
infrastructure projects so why didn't
all that extra money have a bigger
effect on the economy
well Maryland Governor Martin O'Malley
cut infrastructure spending more than
enough to offset any gains from the
stimulus see before the stimulus
Maryland's Transportation Trust Fund
paid for highway repairs by collecting a
special gas tax and other user fees
after the stimulus money was available
Governor O'Malley rated the fund to the
tune of 861 million dollars over the
next three years to pay for things that
have nothing to do with infrastructure
even if you account for the stimulus
money which totaled 771 million dollars
state funding for transit infrastructure
still saw a net decrease of ninety
million dollars after the stimulus was
passed large government contractors got
a disproportionate share of stimulus
funds according to an August 2009 report
and government executives the fastest
way to spend government money is to
spend it on channels that already exist
give it to gum
contractors that you've already hired to
just do more of the same thing and that
goes against the philosophy of the
stimulus that's what happened in
downtown Silver Spring were a hundred
and thirty eight million dollars in
stimulus grants and contracts went to 46
organizations but just three firms got
51% of the money these three firms were
major government contractors before the
stimulus was signed in fact the stimulus
money they received pales in comparison
to what they were already getting from
other government contracts take
Palladium partners a communications firm
in Silver Spring it's received ninety
seven and a half million dollars in
government contracts over the past
twelve years after the stimulus was
passed the National Institute of Health
which is pleadians biggest client gave
the firm 795,000 stimulus dollars to
disseminate information about how the
NIH was spending stimulus money with the
project 80 percent done the firm has
also been well paid for what it's
accomplished it built a website that
aggregates press releases and reprinted
news items from other websites so far
it's contributed 29 original articles to
the site averaging just over a thousand
words each it's allowed the firm to hire
two new employees neither of whom was
unemployed before coming to Palladian a
california solar energy company called
Solyndra burned through more than 500
million dollars in federal loan money
taxpayer money only to declared
bankruptcy earlier this month the
Solyndra bankruptcy may be the biggest
green jobs fiasco paid for by the
stimulus but there were others the
stimulus also financed a five hundred
million dollar program to train and
recruit 80,000 people to work in green
jobs with the grant more than half over
the program has found jobs for only
8,000 people in downtown Silver Spring a
union backed organization called the
Transportation Learning Center
participated in that program received a
five million dollar grant the money was
to teach new green job skills to public
transit employees and to recruit and
train three thousand ninety five people
to work in the transit industry but a
year into its grant the Transportation
Learning Center got permission to back
out of its commitment to place people in
jobs because they've changed
economic conditions so now it's using
the entire grant to teach new skills to
transit workers forty have jobs the
spirit of the stimulus shouldn't be
yet people already have a job and
already her doing things to get more
money to do the same thing just bigger
government spending should be actually
going to places where unemployment is
very high going to people who are
poached from unemployment lines we're
going to weatherize amish that
immediately puts people back to work
what would be a more effective stimulus
package than that so the idea of
stimulating the economy through spending
you wonder spending to get in the
economy right now four months after the
stimulus was passed Governor Martin
O'Malley held a press conference at the
Silver Spring home of Sonya and Richard
Lowry the weatherization program was
underway and then it nearly ground to a
halt in the first year Maryland
weatherized
only 279 homes or 4% of its goal of
6,800 nationwide 5 billion stimulus
dollars were set aside for weatherizing
homes a year into the program just eight
percent of that money had been spent a
February 2010 report by the Department
of Energy's Inspector General found that
the job creation impact of what was
considered to be one of the department's
most shovel-ready projects has not
materialized the main hold up was a
concession to organized labor the
workers paid with stimulus money had to
earn at least the prevailing wage for
their area that created enough red tape
to paralyze the program in its first
year before workers could be paid
Maryland like every state spent months
conducting detailed surveys to determine
average wages and benefits for every job
function in every County today Maryland
is racing to spend the remainder of its
weatherization money before it's forced
to forfeit what's left in early 2012 I
think the main lesson of the stimulus is
creating jobs is a very complex process
and certainly it can be directed by a
top-down institution that pretty much
fails of everything it does
[Applause]